New Yorker writer Jane Mayer gave an interesting
interview to NPR's Terry Gross a few days ago.
And the topic was whether Donald Trump might
end up being the first president to ever be
criminally charged. Now, as I've said before,
I maintain and believe that Donald Trump will
never see the inside of a prison cell. Some people
write to me and they tell me I'm wrong. Well,
I mean, we can't say I'm wrong yet. It hasn't
happened yet. Some people write to me and say,
David, when you say that it makes it less likely
Trump will go to prison, I don't think me saying
it makes it any less likely. But the fact that
I don't think Trump will ever see the inside of
a prison cell doesn't mean he won't be charged.
And as Jane Mayer points out in this interview
with NPR, which you can find online, there are
a number of viable paths to Donald Trump ending
up with criminal charges against him being the
first president to have such charges against him.
Right now, we know of two possible criminal
charges, investigations with possible criminal
charges coming. The first is the investigation
in Georgia over Donald Trump's now known multiple
phone calls trying to get the election results
changed in the 2020 Georgia presidential election.
The second one and the one that actually predates
the Georgia probe is the one led by Manhattan
District Attorney Cyrus Vance, which is looking
at Trump's financial practices and in that one,
tax banking, insurance fraud all on the table. And
that's the one where they finally got a decision
from the Supreme Court that indeed Trump's
financial records must be turned over and
they have been. So now Cyrus Vance has those
records. Now, as I've said before, the most
likely scenario is some kind of financial charges,
probably against others at the Trump Organization.
But still, it's possible Donald Trump could be
criminally charged in that investigation. Jane
Mayer addresses many of the important questions.
For example, Terry Gross asks her whether even
if Trump committed crimes, we should just move on
because Trump is gone. And Jane Mayer points out,
listen, it's true that lots of the countries
that charge former leaders with crimes
are not necessarily the countries we're
trying to emulate. But she argues that if
the crimes Trump committed aren't even related
to the presidency, these are business crimes,
for example. What reason is there not to pursue
to pursue them? And this is an important point.
We know that every president makes decisions that
lead to deaths, but we don't charge presidents in
those cases because it would make being
president impossible. I'm not saying
that I'm against war crimes charges. That's not at
all what I'm saying. But every time you cut aid or
shift military resources, send troops into war,
change some welfare program to a drone strike,
every presidency leads to civilian deaths, some
of which could have been avoided. Right or wrong.
U.S. presidents don't get charged with that stuff
and we can have a debate about that. But that's
not what we're talking about here. If we find out
Trump was laundering money through his business,
who cares if he was president for a four year
period? It's unrelated to him being president.
And there shouldn't be a culture of impunity.
As Jane Mayer correctly points out, the possible
financial crimes and fraud in New York are
significant, taking tax deductions on things
that aren't tax deductible to the tune of millions
of dollars, including even some of those hush
money payments that Donald Trump made exaggerating
or diminishing the claimed value of real estate
to manipulate lenders and taxation authorities
to his benefit. There's a very long list here,
and these are crimes in the state of New York on
the. End of this, the question of prison comes up
are the things being investigated theoretically
punishable by prison time? Yes. Would Trump get
prison time even if found guilty? It's possible.
Would he serve it? I can't imagine. Jane Mayer
says in the interview she believes Trump
would flee the country if he actually were
sentenced to prison time. The truth
is, I don't think that's very likely,
but we're in such unprecedented territory that
it's very difficult to predict. My sense is the
most likely scenario is there's no prison time
and Trump doesn't have to flee. I still believe
that's the most obvious and logical scenario.
The importance to me of criminally charging Trump
isn't to put him in prison. It's twofold. First,
it's to show that a president isn't above the law
and maybe that will prevent another president from
being as corrupt and criminal as Donald Trump.
Maybe that's naive, but that's
one important element of this.
Secondly, as a very practical matter, if there
are criminal charges against Donald Trump,
it could just keep him too busy to even think
about running again in twenty, twenty four. And
that would be a very good thing. We'll have
more coverage of this on The David Pakman Show
Instagram. You can follow us there at David Pakman
show. Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman if
you want to see me. What would be the right word?
And that's not really accosted, smothered by a dog
that doesn't understand the concept of personal
space. Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.